or forest ecosystem is inherently very
very complex there are an awful lot of
organisms in there from the big things
that are very obvious like the trees and
the animals to the smaller things that
are much less obvious the fungi and the
smaller insects and the wood-boring
insects that we don't really see much of
on the outside so it's a very complex
space indeed an organism which might act
as a food source for one organism might
act as a shelter for another or even be
a predator for another organism the
sheer level of detail was something
incredible what we're trying to do with
living symphonies is create a piece of
music which portrays in real time a huge
web of interactions that make up a
forest ecosystem a site-specific
Symphony in effect
the first step is to select forest which
is really diverse in terms of its
ecology and we then go out there and
survey the huge array of flora and fauna
that inhabit that forest we go out to
the forest in question pick out a 30
meter by 20 meter area of the forest and
painstakingly examine every square meter
of that forest segment for the wildlife
that lives within it so we're trying to
spatially map how all of the flora and
fauna that are likely to appear within
that area with the forest scientists
when they begin to build models of this
kind of system usually start from what
the organisms are and from the organisms
you then begin to build their their
quantities and their relative quantities
and their interactions what eats what
what has a mutualistic relationship with
what so very rapidly from a number of
organisms and their interactions you can
develop this great complexity and from
that we hope to begin to understand that
the patterns that emerge as functional
patterns in the system
the simulation itself came out of the
research that I produced as part of my
doctoral studies which was a very simple
abstract model of the way in which
social organisms interact over a long
time scale this simulation for living
Symphony is an extension of that which
takes it and applies it in a multi-level
format to the whole array of organisms
which live within this particular forest
what we see here is a visualization of
what's going on beneath the hood of
living symphonies this area marks out
the real area of Thetford forests that
we've surveyed for its flora and fauna
so in the centre here we have a cluster
of Hawthorn trees and Elms around the
edge we've got a few pine trees which
are portrayed by these circles each of
the tiny triangles portrays an
individual organism so we've got wrens
hopping around the forest floor and a
moth flying around here which seems to
have found some food and up here we've
got a pair of buzzards which are
circling on the thermals overhead
and then
after the survey process is complete
every single species is allocated a
musical motif that is composed for it
and is heard back wherever the species
is so if it's a tree it's heard back by
the tree if it's a moving thing then
it's heard back moving based on the
simulation of where that thing might be
moving and what it might be attracted to
the really key thing is that each
organism doesn't just have one set of
melodies which describe it it's got a
whole set of sequences each of which
corresponds to a different activity
state so the squirrel when its foraging
will sound very different to the
squirrel when it's eating or when it's
mating or when it's just idly exploring
one of the ones I've been working on
recently is Buzzard one of the main
activity States for buzzards is when
they pair and fly together
so there's interlocking melodies that
can work together so this is the main
melody for Buzzard and then you have
another option and so an alternate
Buzzard paired with it
so those two things can circle about the
canopy together at the same time and the
whole composition is kind of made in
that way coming into this space has just
been magical begin to hear some of the
sounds
some of the higher canopy sounds from
further away and as you get closer and
closer you begin to hear the lower
canopy sounds and and we were all sort
of picking up our ears one of the
biggest misunderstandings I think that
can be easily made with the work is that
we're somehow magically tracking every
hand and every fly in every button
because we're operating from a model
it's it's basically our best possible
guess based upon research survey and
knowledge from a lot of people that
we've worked with in science when we
make predictions with our models we tend
to make predictions about perturbations
here they've done something very
different in that they've created this
model and then put it back into the
space reflecting in real time what might
be happening in there they're trying to
reflect what is now whereas for most
scientists we tend to predict forwards
and say what will be as a function of
something that will happen
from the point of view of the audience
and people that come to listen to the
piece and experience it I hope that they
will treat it as a platform for
exploring forests and the ecosystems
within it and learning more about it
through the piece I I think that coming
into a space like this today especially
with my children will change their
response to how I talk about it I think
that although I talk to them a lot about
what organisms are there and how things
work they will be opened by this
experience as an ecologist I am gaining
so much just by coming in and
contemplating this in a different way
and having this whole different
dimension added to the experience so yes
I think science games and people gain
and music gains and full credit to the
imagination of the people who are doing
this